los demócratas se respiran con algo de
alivio tras los primeros resultados de
las elecciones de medio término en
Estados Unidos aún mantienen esperanzas
de ser mayoría en el senado y su pérdida
en la cámara no sería tan grande como se
había pronosticado salen airosos de
estos comicios para responder esa y
otras preguntas estaba con nosotros
Daisy báez estratega demócrata y ex
representante estatales de la Florida
por el partido demócrata Daisy gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros y le
pregunto fue subestimada a la fuerza de
la campaña demócrata para defender por
ejemplo el aborto en estos comicios Al
final este tema pudo evitar a la marea
Roja en el congreso diría usted que se
capitalizó el voto de la mujer
absolutamente muchas cosas y que
influyen naturalmente pero
definitivamente la mujer saliendo a
votar y saliendo a expresar su ansiedad
sobre los que hemos visto pasar no de
que en las legislaturas estatales se
están poniendo trabas a la habilidad de
la mujer de tomar decisión sobre su
cuerpo Este es un tema económico de a
propósito donde planificar tu familia es
algo que influye en como en tu futuro en
tu vida no y en la caída del Rover
versus wade en a nivel Federal por la
suprema corte en la noche de anoche fue
como diríamos malas noticias buenas
noticias no ha sido el baño de sangre
que se esperaba se naturalmente si vamos
a perder los demócratas van a perder la
cámara de representantes Pero no por el
número anticipado no van a tener una
súper mayoría que le permitiría pasar a
arrasar y pasar cualquier tema
legislativo por la cámara y la el senado
continúa aún en veremos
en este momento está todavía en 47
a 48
48 por los demócratas 47 para los re el
que llega a 50 primero es el que tendrá
control del senado hay varias contiendas
que estás que están por decidirse
todavía aunque
enfermen ganó en Pensilvania una al
doctor ass una una que una continua que
se había vigilado mucho por las personas
pero Kelly en Arizona y otras contiendas
Todavía están sin decidirse Así que
vamos a ver mucho mucho por ver en los
en las próximas horas yo diría bueno que
en este panorama que usted nos está
pintando de resultados no tan malos
mejores de lo esperado bueno Cuál es su
opinión sobre la gobernabilidad de Joe
biden desde aquí a lo que le queda de
mandato suponiendo un escenario en el
que los republicanos definitivamente
dominen la cámara y bueno tengan ustedes
oportunidades de dominar en el senado
Yo creo que el escenario es positivo en
general el presidente byden ha podido
pasar varias de sus paquetes
legislativos por el congreso y el senado
este manda un mensaje que todavía si
mantiene control del senado todavía
puede seguir pasando piezas legislativas
y continúa teniendo El poder del veto
que es muy importante en este país
Aunque pase la cámara Y pase el senado
lo que quieran él todavía puede vetar
cualquier belleza de legislación por eso
es importante que no tengan una súper
mayoría porque entonces la súper mayoría
podría
vetar el veto no hace que mucho por
verse el presidente continúa enfocado en
la economía y que sabemos que fue el
tema principal de muchos de los votantes
las personas votan con el bolsillo las
personas votan como se sienten que
pueden mantener a sus familias Cómo se
sienten seguras sobre Su futuro
económico y creo que si hay algún
mensaje para los es la economía como
decía el presidente Clinton es
no la economía Es realmente el principal
motivador de las personas a salir a
votar y es algo que el presidente va a
tener que enfocarse en este segunda los
estos dos siguientes años a que le tocan
bueno es que ciertamente el tema de la
inflación y la preocupación por el
empleo hizo que perdieran ustedes votos
en esta elección de medio término Pero
además a lo largo de este mandato ha
hecho que pierda mucha popularidad de
Joe biden y esto lo traigo a colación
porque no estamos ya tan lejos de una
nueva elección y hay que empezar a
plantear las figuras que la van a
enfrentar entonces usted fue
representante de Florida y como bien
sabe pues se dio una reelección no más
que exitosa de ron de santis que se
consolida como presidenciable también se
consolida como presidenciable otro
gobernador en Texas y pues está el
propio Donald Trump fue que ha sido una
figura protagonista aún después de dejar
la casa blanca como prevén ustedes
demócratas se retar a estas figuras para
las presidenciables
efectivamente la la campaña para el para
el para la presidencia empieza hoy en mi
opinión los comicios del 24 hoy se
empiezan a definir porque vamos a ver
personas ya enfilando hacia la casa
blanca todavía está por verse si el
presidente Joe biden va a optar por la
reelección y por el partido de
republicano el presidente Trump ya está
mandando un mensajitos y se espera que
va a anunciar su candidatura pero
también sabemos que el Gobernador de la
Florida Run de santes claramente tiene a
la Casa Blanca en su mirilla al igual
que como dices tú el gobernador de de
Texas La pregunta es
las elecciones primarias de que eligen
el representante de cada partido son
lideradas por los militantes del partido
no y los militantes del partido tienden
han demostrado que están detrás del ex
presidente Donald Trump Así que do
van a tener que batallarse el uno al
otro y eso Ese sí va a ser un baño de
sangre para ganar la nominación del de
los republicanos Así que está muy
interesante lo que va a pasar en los
próximos meses
definitivamente
mucho por verse Pero
tenemos todavía que ver lo que termina
de pasar hoy como se deciden estas
elecciones Y si el presidente mantiene
el senado tiene tiene todavía cierto
poder legislativo Claro pero le pregunto
directamente por el futuro de Joe biden
no salió tan golpeado pero
pero según las encuestas la gran mayoría
de los votantes demócratas aún así
preferirían otra opción como nominado
del partido para el 2024 Usted cree que
Joe biden irá por la reelección Y bueno
pues también tengamos en cuenta que es
un hombre ya de 80 años
efectivamente hay mucha conversación
dentro del partido demócrata sobre qué
Cuál es el futuro de Joe biden luego de
esta de estas de este término No él va a
terminar estos dos años mi opinión
conciertos cierta cierto poder cierta o
todavía cierta habilidad de legislar la
pregunta es si se va a reelegir él no ha
dicho una cosa la otra es realmente es
una persona de mayor ya se le ve un poco
cansado un poco ya con no la misma
habilidad La pregunta es pero es como es
el presidente él tiene la opción de
decir me voy a reelegir y yo cualquier
otra persona del partido demócrata puede
optar por también tirarse postularse
para para correr para presidente eso no
se ha definido definido todavía Así que
está eso está por verse